[Music]
in the previous video I stated that
Monarch Legacy of monsters will showcase
their trailer their full trailer in the
coming week or sooner well guess what
sooner is here and let's break down the
trailer piece by peace there are
interesting monsters here that you
should see let's get to it the first
four scenes before the beginning of the
trailer shows nothing much but Lee Shaw
portrayed by Kurt Russell and white
Russell as well as San Francisco after
the mut battle and also Kate Randa who
is now confirmed to be the granddaughter
of Bill Randa okay Split Second scenes
of Godzilla Breaking the Waves in bikini
at all and a group of people running
from an overturn ship in probably Skull
Island or an island nearby to it so
that's that so the beginning of the
trailer starts with Kate explaining what
she saw in in San Francisco on that
fateful day that Godzilla batted the
mutos mind you the Titans and the mutos
as they were known at that time to
Monarch were top secret and virtually no
one in the world knows about their
existence so it was shocking to Kate and
yeah probably a lot of people around the
world when they saw a lot of soldiers
and people with cameras documenting the
fight as if they knew this was coming
this was what Kate stated she saw these
soldiers coming in and also people with
cameras at and they don't really seem
shocked about it so it was also highly
observant of her showcasing her likeness
to her father and grandfather the one
who led the team to Skull Island in 1973
she then recognizes the Monarch logo
which probably turned on a switch in her
mind like a light bulb recollecting what
she had seen before in one of her
grandfather's items a satchel Left
Behind for her the scene shifts to Skull
Island or maybe it's not sky island but
another island in the Pacific Pacific
two people are seen standing by in
amazement as they come across a US Navy
battleship from World War II stuck in
the middle of nowhere and it's rusted
their first question would be how can a
ship travel on land and get so far well
since they are probably on a monster
Hunting Expedition to unravel Secrets
passed down also reports of giant
creature sightings they would probably
have guessed it would be a gigantic or a
massive unidentified terrestrial
organism that you know drag the ship
Inland by the way these two the white
guy and the Asian woman are Bill Randa
and probably his wife Kiko now shifting
to modern times it seems that the files
Kate had retrieved or duck up were
classified and Beyond top secret they
seem to be on the run from the
government or the organization of
Monarch but you know how this usually
goes in TV shows and movies they would
first try to escape then run away resist
and then end up working with Monarch all
the organization C in the end it is an
evil it is how to safeguard Humanity
from these monsters and Titans and as
she stated this is a world that they
live in a world full of monsters and now
she knows that she is Stuck In The
Middle With valuable information that
she holds that is more important to
Monarch than she can
imagine then we see young B Randa
exploring the ship which seems to be
filled with an unnatural slime
disgusting this shifts to a random set
of scenes one which shows the talents of
of the black flying monster wrecking the
ship from inside probably awakened from
Deep Slumber since in the previous
teaser it was seen breaking out from
that particular ship then there was
another scene of Kate's father who was
also a part of Monarch as suggested so
Bill Randa koiko and Lee Shaw are part
of a group that are sent to investigate
reports of sightings and monsters which
leads them to an abandoned Factory site
in the 1950s there they come across
shiny Amber like glowing eggs that
adorin and whoops they awaken in the
Swarm like creatures which seem to be
insectoid which might be shinamura since
the only Titan that is described to be a
swarm entity is the dreaded shinamura
from the 1940s and 50s so the timeline
coincides and also the habit of these
creatures it also seems that they are
either extending the 2017 Skull Island
sequences of the mother long legs or
they are reimagining B randa's Fate on
that island personally let's not go far
as Furious on this Universe we don't
want human resurrections just Godzilla
please anyway he seems to be running
away from a large adult Mother long legs
reaching the shoreline probably where
the mother long legs will end up
battling the giant crap likee creature
you know the one seen in the previous
teaser come to think about it again this
could be part of the movie where Randa
runs off or this scene wasn't shown but
can be connected quite smoothly with the
events of Skull Island of
2017 now this next scene is beautiful we
are transported back to the modern era
where the new team of Kate and the old
leaw and the others are seen in
Antarctica where they come across a
gigantic monster and also what seems to
be a hollow Earth portal so this
gigantic monster seems to be
Subterranean this monster has 8 to 10
eyes on 8 to 10 flexible stalks like
those seen on snails let's call him the
snail crawler it also has a large mouth
full of Shar teeth and as Powers our ice
breaths which are quite the opposite to
Godzilla which are Atomic heat breaths
it also can suck in a lot of air at the
same time reducing the temperature to
minus levels we do not see the entire
body but Split Second scenes show it to
be the size of a large skull crawler and
being quadrupedal with four legs maybe
50 to 60 ft long hyper carniverous by
the looks of it and definitely not a
Titan rather just another deadly super
species the Monarch trailer ends with a
few different scenes of Godzilla and
leaw stating from the background that
they need some help if they want to save
millions of people uh help from who who
else the king of the monsters the group
are seen in the middle of the desert and
Godzilla Rises surprisingly from the
ground with beautiful CGI and the Sands
falling down from his body ooh this
sequence is also jumbled up with the
Godzilla Breaking the Waves and rising
up from the oceans in the 1950s just
before the atom bomb explodes and he is
seen from an angle that makes him look
like a mountain
but the most peculiar thing about this
is that it shows two types of Godzillas
well not really two types but one that
has the 2014 straight Spike dorsal
plates which is the scene in the ocean
and the one in the desert has the 2019
dorsal plates we might just get a full
explanation as to how Godzilla develops
these plates and how long it takes for
him to evolve into a different stage
anyway that's our first breakdown on
this trailer and we will continue with a
few more videos on this in the coming
days so if you like this video then
watch this one as well and if you're
more interested in Monster movie content
and creatures then check out our Channel
as well we might just have things that
you haven't seen or thought about like
subscribe and we'll see you on the next
video take care fam